how's it going everyone it's
international master Danny wrench here
back on chest comms YouTube channel and
today on our to-do list as you can see
from the title is the fried liver attack
and know this is not a disgusting
English meal I'm just joking fried liver
sounds delicious but let's do it like
this the main point of the fried liver
is that white is trying to take
advantage of the weakest square on the
board any beginner player who's had some
basic training or if you read some of
the most important principles to
understand when you first start to learn
chess is that f7 and correspondingly f2
are the weakest squares on the board
because they are only protected by the
king one example that most beginners and
let's say non tournament players will
try to use to take advantage of that are
the four-move checkmate switch can start
with the development of this Bishop
followed by the development of the Queen
and if black doesn't know what he's
doing he brings the knight to f6 and bam
white backdoor checkmates him another
theme that has to do with the weakest
square on the board so this is not a a
lesson on the form of checkmate or every
possible option to take advantage of the
weakest score on the board it's we're
just showing you that here as to make
you aware of the theme and one of the
one of the main things that makes the
fried liver tick which is that if it
wasn't for the fact that this evidence
f7 Square was so weak this entire idea
of whites King Bishop and Kings Knight
coming together to attack that Square
wouldn't be possible
so Knight of three is actually not a bad
move and it develops with the purpose to
attack the pawn you see that many
mainline openings including the Spanish
rule Oh PES the scotch game and the
Italian game which is what we see here
with Bishop c4 I'll start with this move
to Knight of three now here black has a
couple options and the main two are
Bishop to c5 and Knight f6 Bishop to c5
is a move that would completely avoid
the fried liver because it leaves the
Queen open to guarding this g5 Square
taking away the possibility from the
knight however Bishop to c5 opens up
other possibilities including the Evans
gambit as
some of the sharpest variations of the
Italian game being ideas for D for the
shoka piano ideas what are not nearly as
effective with without the target of the
Bishop on c5 aka these two breakthroughs
so Bishop c5 is perfectly playable but
so is Knight f6 and so many people will
play Knight f6 to avoid the Evans gambit
and some of the sharper sharper
variations of the joka piano but in
doing so they allow this move Knight to
g5 so what you see here is the bishop
and Knight lining up to attack the
weakest Square on the board just like
the Queen and the Bishop do and the
scholars made of the form of checkmate
the difference is here you're not
threatening checkmate but you are
actually threatening to win a large
amount of material if this pawn falls
either by check you will lose your right
to castle and I will have won upon and
if it falls by the knight I might follow
that with winning an even further amount
of large materials so it not pretty
potentially right there are a lot of
good reasons to play the fried liver if
you're white mainly the ones I just
listed the reward is very high even if
the risk is high the reward is very high
and so especially at beginner levels of
chess and amateur levels before you get
into organized tournament play it as I
would call it where people have a pretty
good idea of how to handle this I would
recommend the fried liver as a step for
a lot of beginner players looking to get
a quick win it's a very sharp attacking
style to take against your friends and
other people who may not be suspecting
this type of very quick assault on the
kingside so if you're tired of playing
for the four-move checkmate at the very
beginner levels which probably doesn't
work anymore once you've done it one
time they don't fall for it the fried
liver is a much more I say sound way to
go for taking advantage of legal score
the board now ice a sound with you know
my best dr. evil quotation fingers in
the air because it's all relative to the
level that you're playing at right it's
all relative to your own perspective and
it's not the most sound opening at the
high levels of chess because what does
it do it breaks a principle very early
it moves a piece twice before completing
the development one of the most
important principles to becoming a
strong tournament chess player is that
you complete the development of all of
your pieces particularly your minor
pieces and getting castled before you
think about anything
the only exception would be if your
opponent gives you a large amount of
material okay obviously you might take
it but otherwise you don't you don't
break that principle and lose your focus
in terms of completing your development
there can be there can be dire
consequences to that sort of thing
but before we show you some of the best
ways for black to tackle the fried liver
aka the consequences let me just give
you an example line let's say that black
makes a wasted move or doesn't know how
to deal with this
if this pawn Falls would check as I said
this position is already incredibly
devastating because the King has lost
his right to castle and the night is
still threatening to come in
don't don't even forget the whites of a
pawn but also is simply taking what the
knight immediately will also take away
black strike to castle because after the
Queen shields herself will be taking the
rook so this is not even not this
certainly not child's play it's not even
funny to consider the white is actually
a pollen and a rook in this position and
even if this Knight got trapped and lost
itself
white would still be up a serious amount
of material so just wanted to show you
that the reward is there as far as
justifying the risk but what can black
do against it well there are two ways to
play against the fried liver two main
ways the the most concrete way is this
move d5 which pretty much takes care of
the direct job of blocking the bishop
scope to this f7 Square and we're going
to talk about that in a second because
it's the most concrete in the way I
would recommend for players to play is
black but another very sharp way to play
in a very risky way to play one that if
you have time at home or if you have
access to some software meaning some
databases of collected Grandmaster games
and other master games you might look
into this move Bishop to c5
theoretically I believe it's supposed to
be good for white but I say that I
believe because I there are so many
different ideas that have been tried and
with the help of computer analysis and
all kinds of sacrifices becoming
possible I honestly do not even know
what the most current theory is in this
position but what I can say is that
blacks idea is to counteract White's
loss of time of development with a
sacrifice and an attack of zone for
example if ninety xf7 is played after
Bishop takes F to check before dealing
with the fork the King has to has to
take care of his own problems well
taking this bishop would allow another
check
and if the king makes any sort of
unsuspecting move we might get another
tempo move which comes in threatens
checkmate and if black doesn't know if
white doesn't know what to do next you
might see another piece joining the
attack and after this pawn pushes
another piece joins the attack so this
is one way for black to get lots of
attacking chances in the move King e2
walks immediately into this move 94
Czech followed by similar stuff so this
idea of Bishop c5 followed by taking on
f2 is sort of a counter blow to White's
idea of taking advantage of the f7 weak
square it's blacks idea of taking
advantage of White's f2 square and the
lack of development as well that White
has in his position so again Bishop to
c5 followed by taking up - I can say
that the most theoretically popular move
for white for a long time was the move
king of one declining to take this
bishop and therefore allow the
floodgates to open in terms of all the
blacks pieces coming in but this
position is still very unclear even
after the move Queen e7 Knight takes
here it moves like d5 opening of the
bishop to come and even Knight takes e4
immediately oh no 19 c4 immediately runs
into this check but the move d5 followed
by more pieces joining the attack still
leaves this position really complex so
if you have some time and you want to
counteract the fright liberal with a
really exciting idea and you're into
those kinds of positions then Bishop to
c5 is for you but the most positionally
sound way and the way the highest level
people take advantage of this move
Knight to g5 is the most concrete way to
do so which is simply to stop the threat
by playing this move d5 black is
actually cutting off the scope of the
bishop and so indirectly guarding the f7
pawn making this Pony feel a little bit
silly actually and if I move like Bishop
takes d5 were played to immediately
renew the threat black would eliminate
the bishop and then pick up this Knight
and at the end of a long series of
forced moves like this black may find
himself in a winning position after a
few different moves and blacks attack is
is pretty overwhelming so the tables
have turned on white fur for his loss of
time in the opening bite by making this
bad move Bishop
hd5 so if this isn't an option white has
to take with the pawn and in this case
black has one last trap to look out for
before he's really sort of put a put a
bucket of water on the on the fried
liver fire and that move is to instead
not plate Knight takes d5 the move
Knight takes d5 opens up the door for
the lolly attack as it's called which
you might think you see the potential
here it's almost as if you wish your
Bishop could have x-ray vision for a
moment and jump past the knight on d5 to
renew the threat on f7 and if you find
the right move here it sort of does just
that this move Knight takes f7 exclam of
iatch King takes f7 Queen f3 check a
ruski followed by Knight to c3 and
obviously King g6 was sort of forced as
any of the move loses the material back
and what black has lost the right to
castle so black must take his chances
with the king of the center but after
the move Knight to c3 blacks on the move
at night to e7 to defend and though this
position with precise play is actually
not just clearly lost for black in fact
I think the position is is more or less
unclear even though with with absolute
precise play black may be okay
White's attack is really strong in a
practical sense we favor white in these
positions a lot because after moves like
castles followed by D for bringing the
rooks to the open files once we complete
development we like White's chances to
throw everything but the kitchen sink at
the black King instead of liking blacks
chances of a piece you see that at a
certain point material itself may not be
enough to justify the initiative that
your opponent's pieces get and that's
something to remember that's one of
things that makes chess hard is the
eventually the ability to weigh these
sort of checks and balances and keep
everything in check and not be too
dogmatic about the evaluation of
material versus the ability to actually
create threats like it's a particular
weakness so that's one of the things
that makes just fun and tricky and so
that's why the fried liver is a lot of
fun to play a lot of people fall for
this trap and allow 9 takes up 7 and the
few people that maybe would know that
black could actually get away with that
move and defend would never play it
because there's no reason to go into a
completely unclear position where one
false step lands their King checkmated
in the middle of the board they'd rather
go to a position that is much more
and one false step might find them in a
little bit of worse position but not one
where their King is getting trapped and
then the game is over so here blacks
next move is usually ninety five ninety
four is another very tricky option here
and after white opens up the rediscovery
this Bishop we get a lot of really
complex variations but we're not going
to go into that now I'm just going to
point it out as an option so that you
guys know it's there and the other move
is ninety a five which is the best mode
immediately forcing the bishop off of
this diagonal and therefore putting a
stop to the fried liver if the bishop
goes anywhere else black is going to
pick up his poem that he sacrificed this
bishop has lost time this Knight is lost
time well I can quickly develop
castlelong and everybody's in happy town
and and so white needs to continue to
make forcing moves to stop black from
picking up this pawn in this night
feeling silly so he plays this move
Bishop e5 Czech Bishop e7 is not the
best move after the move Queen e2 you
can look up the variations there to see
why White's initiative is still pretty
strong the main point is based on the
fact that if you take here I can take
with check and I'm forking that the
Queen and the king at night so it's not
so simple but the best move for black is
to move c6 and after takes takes White
has to retreat the bishop to one of
these three squares and in any one of
them blacks pawn sacrifice is fully
justified with with pretty natural moves
developing moves here kicking this
Knight back to his square kicking it
again potentially in some cases where
the knight may have to go back even
further so that's not fun and in many
cases black is developing and has a full
initiative and a full full set of full
set of tricks to compensate for the
sacrifice of the pawn so again the blind
I recommend against the fried liver is
the variation with d5 Knight a5 and c6
which puts white an awkward position
because always up upon as you saw blacks
initiative and extra development makes
it very difficult for white to I to have
it have a good middle game the positions
are complex at a high level and I
believe the best move theoretically
these days is the move Bishop to d3 to
try to protect the square e for so that
the knight doesn't have to go back here
and allow that kicking that you just
solved the pony but even in variations
like this black is still getting full
compensation and the positions are
complex a lot of fun to play
so white in many cases will regret this
the slight loss of time with the night
here and the fried liver is an exciting
open and hopefully enjoyed this this
quick introduction as an idea to just
sort of give you a general outline of
the concepts behind both white and
blacks approach and we will see you
around on just calm